[Music]
so if you just thought my tears
literally about their bright future so
clear but future argues that we're in a
triple crisis I've got an economic
system that doesn't work and it
certainly doesn't work with most people
in the developed world people can't see
how their child's life is gonna be
better than their life the economy
stagnating the sources of growth are
running out on top of that we've got its
operating consent for the rule of law
this is leading to the rise of a new
authoritarian conservatism in some parts
the world matters the third problem is
not as well understood it is the problem
of technological control the Machine
control of human being which is already
here in the hands of elites and
governments using surveillance the term
large parts of human life for some
people into a kind of airport like you
go through an airport it's like the
control algorithm do this give your
fingerprints are you really you prove it
then you can pass the stage to large
parts of human life are set to become
blank that personal personal
interactions with Forrester's in coffee
shop
they're already proven that for me each
of these three crises economy politics
technology with the cold it's rooted in
what I call the the crisis of the
neoliberal self neoliberalism to be is
the economic system in the last thirty
years where economics replaced all other
dynamics morality human everything's
economic it was fine while it worked but
now it's broken and as a result the
selves we molded around the realities of
a free market economy and a highly
individualized economy those selves are
in crisis and this is what's driving all
the other stuff so these cells you talk
about at one part in your book you
mentioned Millennials and the snowflake
generation directly the criticisms but
they're sort of used to getting are
along the lines of their the sort of the
natural extension of the sort of hippie
movement in the 60s which focused on
the self and the individual being at the
center of the universe when you provide
quite an interesting defense of this
generation of one in people expanding
yeah Luke I do what I want - snowflake
insurrection I want just to take the
word snowflake and throw it back at our
oppressors in the same way as gay men in
my you use the word queer to say no we
are we are something we are individual
unique fragile we melt in the end we
disappear
you know the word snowflake was comes
out of there a scene in Fight Club in
the mid-1990s movie which was meant to
be a critique of Tusken toxic
masculinity it's become like the Bible
but the lad Bible toss of toxic
masculinity the guy says you are just a
piece of crap on a on a donkey you're
not a special silver the I believe human
beings are more than a piece of crap we
are the teleology my theory of human
nature that I draw from Marx is that
human beings have a human nature has a
history that we are born technologists
linguists Imagineers and that makes it
possible to for us to liberate ourselves
from necessity through technological
change and from self oppression through
the mass transformation if you can be
education and culture and liberation
ideas so I think that makes us more than
a piece of dough of the donkey and I
think if we grasp that that that's the
solution to a to a liberation project no
of course the individual human being
brought up in the digital era the
so-called Millennials the circle
even though Generation Y with the
airport there are problems about the way
they have been addressing Collective
resistance there is a tendency what's
the problem the tendency has been
arising through postmodern ideology to
see everybody as the oppressor of
everybody else
ah I think it's also true that we do
many of us participate in the oppression
as a white man certainly do straight
away certainly do English British I
participate with all kinds of a pleasure
but the good thing about centering the
resistance on yourself is the starting
wood is its irreducible when people say
I'm sick of the students demanding of
the right to not be tonight I hate
speech I would distinct the trigger
warnings though I like to I like to say
that the students have a right for
example to not other hate bigger hate
speech perpetrator on their campuses why
because what the new oppressors the Neo
reactionary Newbery want us to do is to
start dividing human beings it's a
biological hierarchy alpha males are
better than beta males beta males better
than women whites better than black
the danger of all that is that you can't
fight that just for you can resist it as
it were as the irreducible human being
don't come in my space don't oppress me
don't harass me don't shoot me you can
do that but we need to go beyond that
but the analogy are using the boom is it
will be well nod to people of my
generation and my grandmother
the working class had to find each other
and act together collectively but that
was until they also had to to formulate
in their mind an objective and I think
what this more looser resistance or
networked individuals from many classes
with many backgrounds and with many
forms of oppression that are stifling
their lives thrust phases find each
other attract the second phase is
formulate an objective you talk about
networked individuals that's quite a new
tone say if you could explain what you
mean in terms of your book so the
sociologists as early as the nineties
observe no hierarchies that had been
formed in industrial society were
breaking down so the family area the
structured workplace with its firearms
we're all breaking down and the first
use of the networked is become term was
to describe people you had to network
because they lived in suburbs they
didn't use devices
they had to live physically join a swash
Club they had to go to a parent group
just to meet people because were work
but be disbursed but once we got digital
technology added to them the sociologist
Manuel Castells
describes the networked individuals as
someone who is spontaneously anti
hierarchical that is remove your
generation moves between many many
different groups I do to be honest i'ma
I have adopted the digital lifestyle
where we were at home is in cities where
we can move from one group to another we
can deploy multiple cells my father's
generation had to have oneself to be to
have two selves was to be a liar was to
be false though the people who suffered
from this with people like gay men who
had to have a real self and a fake soul
but but in general that world of
hierarchy in the single self has
disappeared and now many people are
juggling multiple selves it's seen by
many people kind of reaction
of my generation as a bad thing I don't
think it needs to be a bad thing it can
be something that empowers you to be
able to know that you are capable of
deploying the multiple self but in the
end that multiple self has only one body
and only one world in which to act in
the analog space in the wet world of
human beings and and therefore the the
the networked individual needs to be to
the words find each other and act we
don't come out of my book they're from a
manifesto called the coming insurrection
written on the eve of the 2011 uprisings
by these anarchists from the so-called
invisible committee in France but they
said and I believe this the proletariat
my granddad and grandma they had the
workplace into which define each other
in work in which to work out who's
virtuous who's an [ __ ] who's going to
break the strike who's gonna beat their
partner though they're their wife in a
traditional family who's not we have the
whole of society which to find each
other but we need to find each other
through the network and then we need to
act so it's interesting you talk about
the 2011 protest and two months ago we
saw a really distinct style of protest
in the form of extinction rebellion I'm
sure you've got a lot to say about this
but yesterday it was announced that the
men are going to try and push
prosecution on all of the activists
1,100 actors who were arrested now I saw
a Facebook post that reference Mahatma
Gandhi first they ignore you first they
ridicule you then they fight you then we
win yeah well it's going to take a
little bit of time to win because we're
not just up against the state nor even
is the state the biggest enemy of X are
all of the other groups like me - or
black lives matter even black lives
matter it's that the problem is what
what the German philosopher Hannah
Arendt called the temporary alliance of
the elite and the mob and we're up
against a temporary alliance of
authoritarian elites who keep their
money offshore who are heavily invested
in fossil fuels surveillance
technologies yeah these what these guys
and of course by investing in offshore
that is anti taxation they're
effectively investing in antis
no that's on one hand there are large
numbers of people who need to believe
that climate change is not real who need
to believe that women are subordinate to
men because in there their world will
disintegrate in the next 20 years
because of the changes we need to make
your generation cannot go back into the
box that my grandmother's generation of
women could had to live in or gay men or
transgender people or black people isn't
we're you can't D Network a society you
can't unliberated generation okay
so X are for me is the latest iteration
of the new kind of protest that is there
almost a son and daughter of 2011 and
the Occupy movement the Occupy movement
imagined a new society and we assembled
the forms of that society on the
Internet the networks and then we took
it into physical space in the form of
tent camps and square occupations they
didn't last they were easily repressed
extinction rebellion me too and black
lives matter take it to a visceral level
to a granular level do you think about
what BLM is saying is that the wages of
whiteness is that ever policeman arrives
on a trouble scene black people get shot
of white people generally don't that's
why these races spend all their time on
the phone trying to call the cops on
black people for selling water on the
street what they call is the cop will
arrive and shoot somebody and it ain't
gonna be them no that's a very different
thing that's saying I need civil rights
I need civil rights for Martin Luther
King for Malcolm X etc Stokely
Carmichael was real Angela Davis was
real was a real thing but to say you no
longer have the right to shoot me when
the cops turn up is a is a different
more granular thing it demands changes
of human behavior me too demands the
change in human behavior I work in the
theater sometimes the theater is
undergoing a revolution because of the
demand of female actors and producers no
longer for their physical invasion of
their body space under the excuse of the
theater I'm not just talking about
director saying you know let's let's
have a drink after work you know by the
way you'll get a lovely part in my next
film no it's about the actual
physicality of theater is changing there
is no a movement that helps people act
through whether they have to do a sex
scene or a sexual violence scene both
these things exist in reality and should
be portrayed on stage but now we have
movements where we mediate those and we
allow people to explore what is
happening to them in a much more
reflected way reflective way than before
so what I mean though is the way me too
is not just transforming kind of the
agender of feminism it's transforming in
a real industry it's also transforming
parts of corporate life not enough there
are no tests and courses they call them
the Weinstein test in corporate life you
can you pass the test otherwise you
don't become a director of this bank so
the amazing thing is that going back to
XR that we've got here what's X ARS
number one demand tell the truth we're
at philosophy festival we're routinely
people question the possibility of truth
but I don't and I think that's another
thing there are truths they are
provisional they're scientifically
verified we need to fight for them and
I'm delighted at the XR as come out of
course the states are going to repress
it it's gonna be wake up time when some
quite you know I say you know you're
young and therefore inexperienced
protesters my generation of climate
protesters and people I collaborated
with them reported on I've been trying
to say Luke the cops will come soon
there will be people arriving in your
camps who look unstable you need to deal
with them you need in a good way you
know we get educated care for people but
what the cops then do is that they like
the evil doctor they look they look at
the thing and they go that's an entity
in this occasionally doesn't have to be
our police another country's police it
can be a private security company you've
never heard of they say what are the
what are the illnesses and weaknesses of
this thing how can we make them worse
that's what happens it's what happened
to the tent camp outside alone the stock
exchange that it was quite clear
somebody was exacerbating all the
problems and I don't believe it's the
British stage I believe you know that
the whole world is know a kind of out
sourced there's a kind of state
mischief-making
that's out sourced to private companies
we've never heard of you saw it around
Cambridge analytical and it's pear
company but we can we can defeat them we
are millions of people and what is more
they have sons and daughters who don't
want to live in a burning planet so in
the end we can have an argument we even
with the kind of shittiest private
intelligence company do you really want
to live on a burning planet with chaos
with millions of refugees unstoppably
moving from the global south to the
north if you want to live in that planet
go on disrupting the climate change
movement if you don't then even it might
you know you don't like people with
green hair and nose rings fine just do
it yourself
lobby your Tory MP or your Republican
Congress person tell them to stop
funding climate chaos this is what this
is why for me although I am critical of
institutions like the European Union IMF
World Bank the Bank for International
Settlements and there are people on the
Left who think that it's a good idea to
break it up break up the Western order I
don't I want to reform it I want to
reform globalization that means
sometimes doing less of it ok
less TTIP you know less in globally
focused privatisation of public services
more state intervention I think we're
going to need big state intervention
into the into the energy production
systems of most big countries it might
need to just be taken by the state and
demobilized very quickly - but with huge
losses for the for the investors that's
something I wouldn't do unless we really
have to do it but it it might need to be
done and therefore for me yeah as a
Marxist I do see that the the state as
something we need to use in order to be
able to do this and elites are going to
be our enemies and we're gonna have to
through a mixture of kind of
conversations action I think there is a
model whereby we get somewhere but none
of us can underestimate the urgency know
that the IPCC's report of October 2018
injects into the situation see I just
don't think capitalism can deliver the
load that the radical change in
consumption and production of energy
behavior that we need in 10 to 15 years
however I'm obliged to accept we need to
try and do it with a radically reformed
form of capitalism we have to because
the human resources are not there for
anti-capitalist movement to win the
elections the the corporations are
clinging to the climate model the
economists are clinging to their
economic models so what I want to do in
the next 10 15 years of my life is to
using what we have institutions like
Parliament's economic models climate
science that we have and the persuasive
as a client acumen good bios
biodiversity is not dead yet the
institutions that we have to to enact
that radical change it will it will
probably feel like a non capitalism
because the won't be climate giants
that's the won't be energy giants the
won't be politicians in the pockets of
coal and oil and steel companies they'll
gone if we save the planet but it might
still be a market economy with a big
state sector and in my project a huge
wiki sector a huge open source
collaborative non profit sector that's a
good enough goal and 59 I think by the
time I die I think we can actually
achieve that by the time you die we can
solve climate change
well the books called clear bright
future for a reason for modder Bates
talks and interviews subscribe today to
the Institute of Arts and ideas at IAI
TV
you